[Music]
I'm getting me making the fairly
controversial argument today that
inequality is irrelevant that inequality
doesn't matter from an economic
perspective and then indeed the battle
to establish economic equality is
causing a lot of the problems that we
associate with inequality so let's start
by the fact that recognizing that we
have real problems there are too many
poor people absolutely there's too
little mobility in our economy where
people are coming out of poverty and
succeeding raising to them at a class
and and into wealth absolutely that is a
problem there's a problem at the top of
way too much friendliness you could call
it between business and government
cronyism would be the technical word I
would use way too many people making
money in that sense off the backs of the
taxpayer all of those problems exist and
I would argue and I will argue today
that all of those problems are made
worse by our attempts to deal with the
gap inequality is just a gap it's the
difference between what poor people have
relative to what we have or between what
the middle class has in the ritual any
way you want to measure it it's a gap
from an economic perspective from a
moral perspective from a political
perspective that gap means nothing is
irrelevant and too much energy and focus
is put on that instead of actually going
and solving the actual problems so let's
talk a little bit about inequality and
what it is so let me ask let me start by
doing this how many of you have have
read Harry Potter
all right good love this audience
already this is good
now Harry Potter is a real problem when
it comes to inequality because I don't
know about you but I have calculated
that I have spent thousands of dollars
on Harry Potter I mean you can do your
own calculation but I had two sons they
were about Harry's age every time a book
came out I either I had to go stand in
line at midnight and get two copies oh
they you know and they got older got to
stand in line and get two copies each
hardback copies right because they
wanted the hot off the presses they
couldn't wait and they spent the night
reading it I also wanted to read Harry
Potter I love the books so I had to get
them on audio tapes a third copy so
that's three times 7 21 x about 25-30
dollars do the math then there's the
movies
what are they 67 movies because they
turned every book into two or three
movies to get as much out of us as
possible right so take into account all
the money you spent on the movies and
then add to that the Disneyland rides
and the all the other hobby Potter stuff
that we have had approaches to make our
children happy I spent thousands of
dollars I indeed if you look at my bank
account got poorer by thousands of
dollars because of Harry Potter but the
real evil here is not only did I get
poorer what happened to JK Rowling
she became a billionaire I mean give me
a break this is horrible
inequality exploded I got poorest she
got richer this can't be good we told we
are taught we read in every newspaper
than inequality is a bad thing well
here's an example of inequality she got
rich I got punched she got rich off of
my back my money came out of my bank
account straight I mean a few other
people got rich in the meantime right in
the middleman but straight into her bank
account
and yet we all feel like there's
something wrong with this example right
why why why isn't it comfortable to say
you know this is a bad thing
well because what happened why did we
spend those thousands of dollars of
Harry Potter why did we spend it yeah
cuz we enjoyed it because it gave us
pleasure because it gave us sudden
spiritual values we benefited enormously
I I'm thankful to JK Rollins if I met
Jake Yvonne's throw in the street I
would say thank you for letting me spend
those thousands of dollars no I'm
serious I'm serious I would that's
exactly what I would say to JK Rowling
Wow the pleasure you gave us is
unimaginable very few office have ever
given us as a family not just as a just
for me individually as a family so much
pleasure
so did I really get poorer no I mean I
got poorer materially but spiritually I
think I got richer and I was happy to
give up those thousands of dollars cuz I
had fun I enjoyed it so I am richer for
the having Harry Potter and I don't I am
happy that she got to be a billionaire
she deserves it she made all of our
lives better
she made the world a better place to
live and she got rich who cares life's
not about money I have to remind my
leftist friends of this because the left
seems obsessed about money but I don't
think likes about money I would rather
read the book than have the money in my
pocket I think most all of us would
that's why we gave up the money because
we believed let's say the book cost
twenty five dollars that the book the
experience of reading the book is more
valuable to us as individuals than the
twenty five dollars in our pockets and
that's how inequality is created how do
you become a billionaire this is this is
important guys because you could go out
and if you if you if we figure out
exactly how you become a billionaire
it's open to any one of you
how do you become a billionaire what's
the secret have a great idea lots of
people have great ideas I think I have a
few here and there but I'm not a
billionaire what's that well that's a
shortcut to becoming a billionaire so
let's let's assume we become a billion
in a free market well you can't
manipulate the dictator to give you the
the money right yes yes so in a sense
there's something true there right what
is it that it takes to become a billion
have an idea and and put it into action
I assume create a value create something
that how many people want everybody you
know hundreds of millions ideally right
want it and are willing to pay you what
for it how much are they will need to
pay for it
well not everything what they think it's
worth which for you to become a
millionaire millionaire needs to be what
more than it costs you to produce so the
secret of becoming a billion is very
simple create a product that hundreds of
millions or ideally billions of people
want and if they want it many times over
even better and are willing to pay you
more than it costs you to produce now if
you do that that's every billionaire out
there except for the crooks who you have
used Putin and so on but in in the
marketplace every billion out there
that's exactly how he became a
billionaire Steve Jobs indeed created
this product which costs this one cost
about cuz when I go back to States to
get the new one it's a thousand dollars
why am i willing to pay 600 also this I
I want it
yeah but why am I willing to pay $600 I
want a lot of things I want a Ferrari
since I can't get it for $600 I'm not
buying one right so it's worth it which
means this is worth more than $600 to me
it might not be to you you might not
have one of these I doubt it though
I mean I sure otherwise I couldn't buy
this if I didn't have it I wouldn't buy
it and if I didn't have the $25 to spend
on on Harry Potter I wouldn't buy it
right but I have the money and this is
worth more to me than $600 that's why
I'm willing to spend it and by doing
that I am richer because I have an
iPhone and by the way almost everybody
in the world has one of these so almost
everybody not in the world almost
everybody in the West and in large parts
of Asia has one of these so almost
everybody in the world can afford this
and almost everybody out there is better
off for having one I have a
supercomputer in my pocket this is more
powerful than the Cray computers you
were in the 1980s or the computer that
send man to the moon it's pretty amazing
and yeah somebody became a billionaire
making these thank you Steve Jobs thank
you
because I get a lot more value than $600
out of this this is what to my life tens
of thousands if not more than that up
dollars I can I can I can Skype with my
kids from the other side of the world
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV